you know one thing about these new smart
watches is that they aren't really nice
watches sure this is a fine sports watch
but i'm not going to wear it to a
wedding but that's something pebble's
hoping to change with its newest watch
the pebble steel
the steel still works like the original
power smart watch it brings
notifications from your android phone or
your iphone to your wrist it also has
the same e-paper display and physical
buttons but it's now 10 thinner and
comes in brushed stainless steel and a
black matte stainless steel each watch
will come with a metal and a leather
strap
yet my first impression it still doesn't
feel like a very high quality watch but
pepo might make up for that with new
software enhancements pebble is
preparing to launch a new app store for
both of its watches and it will include
apps from espn pandora and foursquare
the store will be available through the
ios and android pebble apps later this
month
the pebble steel starts at 250
though i'm still not sure if i can get
away with wearing it to a wedding